ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show I just got back from Romania
I want to thank the gentleman that paid
me a sum of money to perform at his
birthday party uh and God bless him uh
the audience didn't speak English
and many of the people there were
heavily intoxicated but they did see a
mentalist and a fireworks show several
uh um Romanian musical acts that were
lovely and me after all of that for no
money uh no for a good amount of money
for me but uh all the people that came
it's free it's birthday party so you got
a lot for that in uh Romania which
everybody was telling me when I left
they were like you got you have to be
careful
Romania is is Eastern blocks so all
ex-soviet country Eastern Europe it is
dangerous
it's really really [ __ ] up
it's safer than La it's safer than New
York it's actually one it's I felt safer
there than I've like ever felt anywhere
there were no tents no homeless people
it was like one old homeless guy it was
kind of cute like you remember when
homelessness was cute it was like a guy
who would do a jig and people would
throw change at him like that's the kind
of homelessness in Romania there was
nothing like what you have here there
were no tent cities nobody was like you
know you weren't seeing the society just
crack apart in front of you yeah the
buildings are rolled some of them are
really pretty a lot of them are they
there's some wear and tear and you know
the attitudes towards sexuality are a
little different
you know if the cab driver there will
get you a hooker like women are
you know there there's it's an
entrepreneurial activity when you go out
um
um but you know we have that here but
there it's like very you can feel it
um but safe not something where you're
like I can't believe like I was thinking
I was going to be walking down the
street they were going to be like a
gypsy Beggars people lunging at me all
of the things that you think about are
actually in Los Angeles they're not
there
they're actually here not there so I
feel ignorant and stupid because we've
all seen the movie hostile with Eli Roth
my director friend who were friends but
I'm a little he's a little into sharks
right now Eli Roth keeps talking about
saving sharks all the time and it's like
Eli do they care about you uh but I love
Eli Roth and hostile is about Bratislava
which is not in Romania I don't know
where it is it's in Serbia
Czechoslovakia who cares the point is it
feels like that's the vibe you think
it's gonna be people are getting drugged
and then you wake up in like an
abandoned Factory and people are
operating on you you lose a liver it's
not like that at all it's everybody
smokes cigarettes everybody likes each
other
from what I saw I'm sure there's
problems
um but I was just there we were talking
about Russia
and we're talking about the problem
we're in we got a little bit of a
problem now
we got a little bit of an issue because
the American Media in their infinite
wisdom has been saying for the last two
months that Russia has been losing the
war
that Russia's a big [ __ ] and that
everybody who lives in Russia can barely
like put two hands together to fight and
the Russian military is useless and
they've been losing the war now
apparently that offended Putin the
leader of Russia uh and the ukrainians
getting like really emboldened which
listen we're all we all want less war
right I want less war
I don't want a nuclear war I don't want
to totally
say that a nuclear war would be horrible
because I think there are a lot of
people in our country who through a lot
of nice editorials including one I
talked about months on the show we're
like hey it's a little bit of a nuclear
war it might not be the biggest deal so
I don't want to listen would a nuclear
war of benefits sure everything has
benefits so I wouldn't want to
completely write off a nuclear war as
all negative I'm sure there's positives
and the people and they'll exploit the
defense contractors will explain to you
the positives of a little nuclear reset
that's why they're just saying tactical
nukes they're using these words tactical
it's not a big it's tactical it's a
tactical new it's a little nuke here and
there boom boom boom but we're on our
way there
because
Russia wanted these two regions they
wanted dunbas and the other one the
people there are majority Russian they
speak Russian a lot of them are
sympathizers with Russia when zelinski
came into Power which kind of like a CIA
coup uh he eliminated that the
pro-russian party so they had no
representation politically in 2014 Putin
annexed Crimea again another kind of
Russian region and you know now we have
this thing where Putin has invaded the
Ukraine to prevent them from from
whatever you wanted to say whether it's
joining NATO or whatever you know they
he is basically going in there and
saying I want these regions that were
Russian they were Russian I want them
and I don't want Ukraine to join NATO
which he's expanded a bunch of times and
it's it's you know Ukraine's on the
doorstep of Russia he doesn't want
missiles there he doesn't want to that's
what he doesn't want okay now yeah is
Putin a great guy no let's go over all
of the [ __ ] uh qualifiers here about
Putin because I people are going hey
yeah you're like listen he's a bad guy
Putin's not good he kills people
indiscriminately or whatever if they're
a threat to him he kills them he
murdered this journalist anapoliskaya we
think but he did like he does Alexander
livchenko poisoned him with polonium
everyone's dying now anyone who's ever
said anything negative about the war
they're all dead he's not a good guy he
we get it don't mistake what I'm trying
to say here I'm not a fan of Vladimir
Putin in the in overall you know
appraisal of his character what I am
saying is that
um he wants certain things
like yes would he like to reconstitute
the Soviet Union sure probably I'm sure
he would but he's been very specific
about what he wants in this conflict and
then the the Ukraine and the us we've
been very like General
we've been very like vague and like very
big picture he's been like done boss the
other one find me the name of the other
one done boss the other one respectfully
I'm you know done boss the other one and
uh he wants that and no NATO and then
our response is
Freedom like that's our response our
response is like Freedom
Ukraine zielinski love Nations trans
people dance
the free you know future the children
and he's been like no no done boss and
that other thing and no NATO and then
our response to that is like here's a
Ukrainian folk song and how dare you
it's like you know and then zelinski the
other day goes I'm not
I'm not negotiating with Putin this is
one of my favorite things I've ever seen
he goes we can have no negotiations with
Putin because he's a leader with no
future it's like
who decided that like he has a future in
Russia
the coups did not work he's still there
I remember in the beginning everyone's
like the Russians will turn on him
they'll kill him they haven't he's still
there he has a future in Russia so now
zielinski is calling essentially for the
removal of the the leader of the country
that has the largest nuclear Arsenal in
the world someone in our government has
to shut him up
someone in our government has to go you
can't you can't do this
this is not appropriate to say that
Putin is a leader with no future it what
do you how does this work out in
everyone's head again I'm not a
geopolitical strategist I'm not a genius
I'm a comedian uh am I right about a lot
of things probably doesn't matter here's
the reality how do we see this working
out Russia taking the owl walking away
Putin looking at the elites of his
country and going yeah well I
embarrassed us all like we couldn't even
beat Ukraine what do you think happens
to him then he will get killed and he
knows that he knows if he doesn't and
then what do you think happens who do
you think takes after uh that takes over
after Vladimir Putin
like uh like a liberal free market no
it'll probably be like another
authoritarian but like they have a list
of guys that could take over after Putin
there's like a list of people
um and if you could grab that there's
like a list of
um generals or whoever that would be
taking Vladimir Putin's Place let's say
there was a coup none of these people
watch RuPaul's Drag Race none of these
people are going to be the types of
people here's some examples so here are
the potential replacements for Putin if
Putin's out
uh here are the progressives that come
in uh they include Alexander bortnikov
Sergey chemazov Sergey narishkin Nikolai
patruskrev Igor Sachin and Sergey shogo
so bordnikov is the current head of the
FSB
which is the Russian intelligence
service
he's uh one of Putin's strongman he's 70
he's a spy he was a spy in the KGB uh as
well and he uh appeared on the list of
those sanctions by the EU after the
poisoning of Alexa and evalier lovely so
that's that's what option uh coming in
okay
option number two will be uh this
gentleman here
um and this guy's name uh here is
let me see it's uh narishkin
he's the head of the foreign
intelligence service the svr
uh and the head of the Russian
historical society and he met Putin in
Saint Petersburg when the current
President worked in the city hall and
like the other bortnikov he was also
accused of being behind the colonies
poisoning number two
that is number two
it's good these are the candidates that
are lining up to
replace uh Putin so then we have uh if
you go up here
we have
Sergey chemazov
who is the CEO of Russ Tech a
state-owned defense company
um he met Putin during his time in East
Germany his position in charge of the
Russia company has allowed him to build
up a large Fortune he has several luxury
Yachts some Villas in Spain
um another key
salivarc in Putin circle's Igor section
Head of the State Oil Company Ross naft
again they both well one is Ross tech
one is Russ naft and like chamazov he
holds one of Russia's greatest fortunes
I would feel more comfortable with the
rich guys because at least they might be
concerned with their own money
um
but go up Sergey show you
is um
one of my favorites this is a great uh
example here
in the military sphere perhaps replacing
Putin will be defense minister Sergey
shogu the military officer of Ukrainian
and two vent Origins is a government
figure who has held a high-level post
since a collapse of the Soviet Union
Shogun was one of Putin's closest
friends uh played a key role in the
annexation of Crimea and the military
operations in Syria
so those are the candidates the
progressive candidates that will replace
Putin and reverse the course of history
in Russia today's episode is brought to
you by true classic guys let's talk
about t-shirts finding that perfect
fitting shirt can be terrible I swear
the thing is either way too tight has a
case of bacon neck I don't know what
that is or just plain big and boxy
luckily true classic wants to make every
man look good and feel good tighter in
the fit chest and sleeves to make your
arms pop and room in the Torso to keep
things cozy plus all of their styles are
super soft and pocket friendly so guys
no excuses get rid of those ratty
t-shirts I know you've been hanging on
to for years and get ready to upgrade we
have an exclusive deal for our listeners
we want to hook you up with some true
classic for limited time get 25 off with
the code Tim at trueclassic.com almost
all men's t-shirts are designed to look
good on a certain body type skinny
models with six packs but most of us
aren't attacking anything but a few
beers
and there's nothing wrong with that my
dudes it's simple you're wearing the
wrong clothes
I am now going to tell you about a time
when I couldn't find a shirt that was
good
one time I went to a store and I
couldn't fit in any of the clothes and I
was angry and sad
a friend of mine said have you ever
talked about true classic and I went
what or he'd seen it or heard of it and
I'm like what do you mean and he goes
well they're more than just a t-shirt
company they have all the Men's Wear
Staples you could need they've got polos
and workout shirts with the same
flattering fit box or brief designed to
keep your boys feeling nice and
comfortable they make it super easy to
build out your wardrobe and you'll get
top-notch quality for Great Value they
have this pack Builder on the website
where you can custom bundle all of their
essential products and save even more
than the discount we're offering you
today
folks get comfortable get going and
upgrade your wardrobe with true classic
get 25 off at trueclassic.com with code
Tim free shipping included on purchases
over a hundred dollars one hundred
percent risk-free guarantee with a
30-day return policy true classic when
you look good you feel good not always
but I don't know if he's a hardliner or
not the hardliners in Russia are the
ones that are like bomb the Ukraine bomb
them back into the Stone Age
which they're doing they just took out
like 40 of Ukraine's electrical grid uh
people you were in Romania and people
like yeah I was talking to Ukrainian
girl on Snapchat she's gone now because
there's no they but Russia's like you
keep saying we're Lou we're just gonna
bomb you maybe our military is not good
on the field but that doesn't matter we
have all the missiles that's that's what
war is now everybody's like the Russians
can't even fight it's like they don't
they have all the missiles that's what
war war is not like uh it's not a UFC
fight they're just gonna go in there and
level the [ __ ] country until these
people and zelinsky I don't I I don't
know if he doesn't understand that or he
thinks he's in a movie but there's other
people too besides this guy
who they've they've they've basically
said that like you know uh Putin if he
goes some of the guys step in there's a
lot of Russian hardliners that want
Putin to turn up the heat and there's a
lot of people that feel like he hasn't
done enough yet you know and so he comes
out after they blew up the Crimean
Bridge he comes out and he just starts
hitting Ukrainian infrastructure blowing
them to bits shutting it down at that
point we should just go it's time for a
deal it should just be deal time
zelinski should go it's time for a deal
let's cut a deal
we're sorry you're sorry we've done
things you've done things let's move on
but instead of that
we are sending more money
sending more weapons and marching
towards nuclear war we're doing nuclear
war drills over the dunbas region of the
Ukraine we're maybe going to nuclear war
over something called dunbas that we
couldn't tell this guy to give up to
Vladimir Putin it's
it's scary when you look at it it's like
actually scary and
I think a lot of people now are starting
to go like okay like this has been a
little this has been a little much but
Putin's not taking yell Russia's not
gonna take the L
um
it's just gonna be a bigger and bigger
issue if you hear it says Russia has
eerily worn the world global Carnage
could ensue if Western allies of Ukraine
continue to meddle in their conflict
this is from a like a diplomat over
there they said World War III could be
sparked if the West continues to
intervene and if a nuclear war was to
occur it would be quote catastrophic For
All Mankind
should NATO approve Ukraine's bid to
join a top Kremlin official threatened
Global destruction Alexander venetikov
the deputy secretary of Russia Security
Council said Kiev is well aware that
such a step would mean a guaranteed
escalation to World War III yet NATO no
no NATO
for them
like it's
this shouldn't even be on the table
they're not joining NATO they're not
joining they're out
this is like it's it's you cannot join
NATO why we're gonna get nuked over this
we're gonna get nuked over this can you
imagine if you're sitting in your
backyard and you get nuked over this
[ __ ] over these two [ __ ] regions in
the [ __ ] Ukraine they speak Russian
anyway can you imagine if you're
vaporized over this garbage
it's it's crazy to me that nobody's
trying to calm this down there's nobody
trying to calm it down everybody's like
Putin's a psychopath he's holding the
world hostage with nuclear weapons he's
sick he should be removed and then what
happens when he's gone like Russia you
shouldn't
poke these people and put them in a
corner where the only way out of it is a
nuclear weapon give them a path give
them a deal here's Don Bess here's
Crimea throw in another [ __ ] that
you get this too give them a third thing
he doesn't even want give him another
[ __ ] you get that
give him zielinski at this point now
this is going to get me in trouble
what if what if the United States teamed
up with Russia
[ __ ] because that's where we are
anyway we belong as the aggressor we
shouldn't be defending anyone or helping
our job is to kill people and lie about
it so what we should do is just just get
zelinski and deliver him to Putin
deliver him to Putin give him done by I
said Crimea because we got to make a
deal and it's not everyone's gonna go
well that's crazy he's going to be
tortured and murdered yes unfortunately
yes but we do have to move on here we've
got to move on the show is taking the
the Ukraine show has taken up a lot of
attention and no one really cares
anymore and every article now is just
like nuclear Wars coming nuclear war is
imminent is it even should we even stop
nuclear war why would we even try to
stop nuclear war let's just all get
adjusted to the idea of nuclear war over
this over the Ukraine over dunbas go go
to dunbas and hit image and let's go all
see what we're dying for
this is we're all gonna die uh dunbas
Ukraine
here it is let's take a nice
photo done boss
let's see if there's any other photo can
we get any other photo of dunbas let's
see if we could get like a no I want to
give them the benefit of the doubt let's
get a nice photo where it's like you
could see because we're all gonna die
over this we might as well have like
some type of idea
it's not that there's no even photos of
this
interesting okay well
well maybe we all die
maybe we all die and uh you know I'm
just just just it's not the move to tell
this guy Putin that he's a loser that's
nice bring that up that's a pretty photo
look at that it's a meadow
okay
there it is it looks like Austin Texas
that looks like Lake Travis
so instead of just giving that dump to
Russia we're all gonna die
that makes sense right so that every
defense contractor in America can sneak
into a private bunker when the nuclear
warheads and then count money great well
what are you gonna do it's not
it's not that bad and I'm I I'm sure
maybe I'm overreacting about it but you
know you're over there in Romania you're
talking to people they're like yeah
Russia's not losing and they don't have
any plans to lose and Putin's just gonna
unleash a holy fire and fury in Hell
which he's been doing and we're like
yeah but did you read the piece of the
New Yorker did you read that the New
York Times Really served it up to Putin
it's like no guys I'm telling you
Putin's been very specific about what he
wants we've been vague in general and in
an argument when someone's very specific
and someone else is just kind of pie in
the sky like very general usually the
specific person kind of has the upper
hand because they're going hey here are
the things that I want they will make
this better and you're going like I
don't even know you it's like that's not
helpful so instead of like well the
freedom and democracy stuff just give
them just give it to them just give them
what he wants give him what he wants and
it'll all be okay because there's no way
because zelinski's so high on himself
the goal here should be less war not
more war should be less zelinski is so
high on himself that there's absolutely
no way that you could see unless Russia
takes a total l
so we're we're setting up a situation
where Russia has to be humiliated on the
world stage understand what that means
understand what it means that we are
putting Russia in a position where the
only outcome that we think is acceptable
is if Russia is completely isolated and
humiliated in front of the world Russia
the country with the the most uh the
biggest nuclear Arsenal Russia that
country we want them to be humiliated we
want Putin to like say sorry do a press
conference apologize pull troops out
admit to losing and we think that that's
gonna have we in our brains in
somebody's brain they think that's going
to happen and it is not probably not so
I would just say we should be a little
careful over there especially speaking
to like some people in Romania some from
the Ukraine refugees like
you know we spoke we spoke to a good
amount of people over there and um you
know I think everybody wants the war to
end
and nobody wants it to end in like a
you know mushroom cloud
speaking of Wars the military is now
doing this thing that it's done many
times before recruitment in the military
is off nobody wants to join the military
right now because everybody is kind of
sniffed out what's going on nobody
really believes
like anything
that the government says about why the
military does anything it does so what
tends to happen is when you have this
like Crisis you basically have a ton of
young people now that go you know
I'll do other things I'll get into
crypto
uh I'll figure it out I'll build a
YouTube channel I don't know but nobody
wants to uh be in the military anymore
so the military is now claiming that it
is woke
that is too woke this is what the the
response is that's why nobody wants to
join it's not because we've seen
Afghanistan and Iraq and all of these
things and everybody is fed up it's
because the military apparently is too
woke meaning that when you join it I
don't know what happens they cut your
dick off
or
so the Army missed its recruiting goal
by about 15 000 new soldiers in 2022
coming up about 25 short of his goal at
a time when each of the services was
struggling to meet their benchmarks
military officials worry that half that
all of the branches have had to reach
deep into their pools of delayed entry
applicants which we know who that is
right it's you know these are the people
that really don't need to be in it they
don't add much these are the people who
we go yeah we'll let you in depending on
how bad things get but for now go home
like if you show up to the recruitment
with your own battle plan drawn out and
it involves your own town they go you go
back home keep doing stuff in the yard
do some sit-ups and push-ups in the yard
and we'll get you back when we need it
so the delayed entry applicants are like
cops that I guess have been thrown out
of the police force for shooting uh
black people and you know just the
people that show up and they you don't
want to take them right away you go you
guys just maybe they have medical things
you know I've I have seizures I've been
you go whatever so now we're we're gonna
have to start using that military
recruiters have leaned on tried and true
factors to explain the challenges
including low unemployment and a dearth
of applicants up to physical educational
and behavioral standards because
remember to join our military you have
to be a brilliant
good person who's never had any
behavioral problems but the truth is I
love this article and this is from
military times because I get it they're
trying to you know this is okay but the
truth is no one keeps detailed data on
what stopping America's youth from
signing up yeah
I I think people have it's called 19
fake Wars
experts and Senior military leaders
point to The Perennial factors of
competition from the private sector and
a dwindling number of Young Americans
both qualified and interested in
military service but what they don't
have too much information on is why the
propensity is going down and whether the
country is undergoing an ideological
shift towards military service one
possibility this is Senator Tommy
tuberville
a republican from Alabama Tommy
tuberville has figured it out
the military is too woke
and apparently people that want to go
die in foreign countries don't want to
be woke and they're afraid that if they
join the military instead of being
immediately sent to their death they'll
be made to read literature about trans
people I don't know so Tommy tuberville
says uh the military is too woke for
example
uh the Republican from Alabama I believe
maybe Alaska I think it's Alabama for
example is among a group of Republican
Senators who have repeatedly blamed
recruiting problems on the Biden
Administration for trying to build a
woke Army
uh the director of the National Defense
at the Heritage Foundation a
conservative think tank recently upon
that wokeness is the quote Chief worry
of grizzled American veterans today is
that true
could that
could that could that possibly be true
listen to the word
wokeness is the quote Chief worry of
grizzled American veterans today
you know
how many people get back from these wars
and kill themselves because they don't
have like you know like mental health
care they have suffering from PTSD they
can't be employed because they try to
get a job as a security guard at
McDonald's but they're trained in the
military so no matter what happens they
start being overly aggressive like
grabbing people and they're like whoa
calm down like you know but their Chief
problem
suicide not it drug and alcohol abuse
not at the chief problem if you are a
grizzled American Veteran I love the
word grizzled
grizzled American veterans meaning
people who've seen and done things it's
like that haunt them
there and their main wokeness is the
main problem
quote the largest threat they see by far
to our current military is the weakening
of its fabric by radical Progressive or
woke policies being imposed not by a
rising generation of slackers but by the
very leaders charged with ensuring their
Readiness wokeness in the military is
being imposed by elected and appointed
leaders in the Y and I don't even by the
way what is the wokeness and like
does this go dead does it say anything
about what the wokeness is
what is the wokeness like if you join
like how gay has the military gotten
like I I haven't been paying attention
but like how woke
is okay in reality service members spend
hundreds of hours a year on mandatory
training covering everything from
operational safety to financial
responsibility and suicide and sexual
assault prevention with a tiny fraction
of that focusing on diversity equity and
inclusion education so I'm wondering
what exactly in the military is super
well I know that they're bringing in new
programs I guess but what is like I I
think one of them is just like let's
keep the assault down because there's a
lot of sexual assault so like just keep
it yeah cutting back home
they're cutting back on rape
yeah well that's woke but I think that I
don't know is it are they doing like
drag shows in the middle like is that do
they do drag queen Story Hour in
Barracks like do these guys have to sit
through I'm trying to in my head Wonder
like what exactly the woke military is I
could be wrong by the way if you're in
the military let me know that I could be
tell me what happened tell me what's so
the offender tube that was going on in
the middle I don't know here's a wait
hold on this is a picture of a woman
this might be getting it here's a
picture of a woman she's on the ground
she's wearing a covered mask okay this
is heading in the woke direct maybe I'm
wrong this is the point in the show
where I go perhaps I'm wrong a U.S
military academy uh Cadet practices
physical training at the Army Combat
fitness test during Cadet basic training
at West Point okay so it's a woman it's
a picture of a woman and she's okay
um
but what seems to incense people is that
the issue of racial disparities
discussed at all not that it's truly
cutting into time spent on train so I
guess they're doing some more like the
race classes
when Marine Corps Reserve Conor Colonel
Matthew F amadon Director of Veterans
and military families at the George W
bush Institute well he did a lot for the
confidence in the military wrote A
Commentary arguing that veterans
veterans to help during the recruiting
crisis process by recommending military
service to their kids and other young
people
military times was inundated with
hundreds of emails from veterans saying
they would do no such thing
their reasons are varied but most said
wokeness is to blame
their reasons are varied many of the
people we sent to kill uh people in the
fake war that we didn't really pay and
they won't have their kids and grandkids
do it and their reasons are varied but
most said wokeness
interesting they accuse the military of
becoming too political or social
experiment
I'll be blunt I wouldn't encourage
anyone to join today's armed forces and
I discouraged both of my sons from
considering serving wrote Peter Dimas
who described himself as a third party
generation veteran quote America's
military leaders have been sold out sold
out the services for their own
advancement and reflect all the poorest
qualities of Civilian leadership
but what is going on can you find
anything about like an example of like
the military going crazy
with wokeness because
with awoke military because because
there's something there is something
here something's going on oh you know I
I think they're overblowing it
but there's something that this is based
on and I just can't
I don't know what it is I know there's
women in the military there's gay people
in the military there's trans people in
the military
we know that
but I'm wondering what exactly is so
over the top maybe they're just teaching
these annoying classes
and it's like you should have a cohesive
unit you shouldn't have like this weird
equity and inclusion I don't even know
why they're you're all gonna die and
we're sending you to die and we don't
even really know why soon it's for the
Ukraine
so
with a woke military whose most senior
officers concerned about white rage he's
a little bit of a clown that guy I've
seen him he likes attention it's that
that's that General who's always like I
want to know why why he's like
auditioning for HBO Max like comedy
special he's like I want to know why
this is this guy I forget his name but
he's he's a big General and he's very
critical uh and he's like I want to know
why white people hate I want to know why
my people hate and like they love him
the New York Times like everybody frames
him up on the cameras you're like he's
great
um
so here we go this is what they're
talking about
um
with the world militaries most senior
officers concerned about white rage
searching for a tattletail process is to
discover
and discharge while white extremists
they want to discharge white extremists
from the military blaming it on toxic
masculinity discharging real Warriors
for not getting vaccinated disagree with
that they should not have done that
that's so stupid
having a two-day stand down to discuss
white extremism that seems in itself
extreme
the promotion and expansion of women in
combat yeah just put them in there see
what happens
some of them will be okay lowering
physical fitness standards to
accommodate naturally weaker women
well you know if you're gonna if you
wanna be in the military and you're a
woman
let let them in and yeah they're not
going to be able to do the same things
men do but they can kill they can kill
children
women can kill babies right I mean I
yeah I don't think it's a it's a problem
um recruiting with social justice and
diversity ads so I don't I don't know
listen
I get it I get it gets a little Annoying
if you're you sign up in the military
and you're like listen just let me at
least hear Let me just fight and die and
don't annoy me which I agree with like
stop with the diversity inclusion like
everybody in the military is the same
they've all joined
many of them didn't have other options
that there they don't have to you don't
have to divide them along the lines of
race or
sex or whatever you're doing just just
let them all go and fight in the Ukraine
they don't have to
I don't know pregnant women are going to
fight our Wars It's a mockery of the US
Military
who said that Tucker
Tucker calls and said that are pregnant
women fighting in the wars
yeah I mean listen man
these fights the ground Wars don't work
we just saw it with Russia these Ground
Wars that everybody said nobody wants to
do that anymore no but everybody's over
that people have Netflix now they don't
care
what what the thing that seems to matter
is just missiles just pressing a button
and then shooting a missile so
I mean I don't know that well you know
if China invades Taiwan does it really
matter if the military is what I mean
we're gonna go in there and fight him no
it's going to be air missiles you know
I don't know I want to talk about the
story in Canada because this actually
made me upset and this made me worry
about
I I usually don't worry about
suicide because I you know it's such a
personal thing
for most people that do it and I
I don't get involved
you know it's but we don't want it but
it does happen and you know but I I it's
sad I don't know
I don't really know too many people have
done it
um and if you're thinking about doing it
you shouldn't
like
unless you know there's there are
things where you know more about
yourself than I do type of thing but for
the most part still no
um but Canada now you can literally I
don't know if you know this you can
literally kill yourself if you've had
like a bad day like if you've had a day
it isn't good you can just sign up for
you did you know anything about that
what
do you go to a pod
is that how it happens
but I don't know that
well I didn't know about the pod
but it could
Canadian mom's harrowing tail harrowing
Tale shows the real dangers of lethal
euthanasia euthanasia when Margaret
Marcilla found out her 23 year old son
scheduled his own death she started her
Race Against Time
sad because this kid he's diabetic his
name's Keanu
uh he lives with his aunt he generally
kept his business to himself
he suffers from depression
stems from his diabetes
is conditioned worse in the summer
creating the loss of sight in one of his
eyes
so he's got [ __ ] going on we feel bad
for that
marcilla's worries for her son's
well-being led her to do a little
snooping with the help of her daughter
with access to his Facebook and email
accounts it was then that she learned
her son had sought and been approved for
medically assisted suicide
part of Canada's medical assistance and
dying law called made which this was
like
mind-blowing to me
no the fact that they would approve
somebody who has like lost their sight
in one eye and has diabetes to just die
at 23. that's [ __ ] insane
um I understand you have late stage
cancer listen
but discovering that her son at just
about two weeks left to live before the
procedure of Marcilla uh began to
investigate the next issue called the
doctor and pretended to be a prospective
patient describing her condition much
like her sons the Doctor Joshua Tepper
seemed accommodating
going so far as to offer a formal
assistant a formal assessment which
could be conducted so it's easy like if
you want out in Canada
they want you out
there they want you out if you want out
they're not asking too many like you
call up you've gone diabetic
one eyes out they go let's do it they
are not pushing back at all
not knowing what else to do Marcelo took
to social media sharing your story and
seeking advice when another physician
who performed made procedures expressed
surprise that Keanu was accepted based
on Diabetes a few decades ago private
citizens used to be largely that private
what changed the internet think about
everything you've browsed searched for
watch tweeted now imagine all that data
being crawled through collected and
aggregated by Third parties into a
permanent public record your record
having your private life exposed for
others to see was one something only
celebrities worried about but in an era
where everyone is online everyone is a
public figure
to keep my data private when I go online
I turn to express VPN there's hundreds
of data Brokers out there who sold
businesses to buy and sell your data the
worst part is they don't have to tell
you who they're selling it to or get
your consent one of these data points is
your IP address data Harvesters use your
IP to uniquely identify you and your
location but with expressvpn my
connection gets rerouted to an encrypted
server and my IP address is masked every
time I turn on expressvpn I'm giving a
random IP address shared by other
expressvpn customers that makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me and harvest my data and the best part
is how easy expressvpn is to use no
matter what device you're on phone
laptop Smart TV all you have to do is
tap one button to get protected so if
you like me believe your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated VPN on the market visit
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon and get an
extra three months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com Jim Dillon go to
expressvpn.com Jim Dillon to get an
extra three months for free I'm trying
to see if they have a number for because
there's a lot of there's too many young
people doing it I don't know how many
are doing it
there so next year Canadian lawmakers
are expected to adjust the criteria for
euthanasia eligibility to include the
mentally ill and quote mature miners the
latter would allow underage patients to
make such decisions for themselves if a
doctor deems them mature enough I don't
know how that happens
so there's a new law that says underage
people can elect to kill themselves if a
doctor will say they are mature enough
to do it
seems like an idea that might have some
issues
but the greatest thing ever is him and
his mom get in a fight at the end of
this article
they get in a big fight
and
she literally says from like I I was
just loving you I just you know this is
what I want to do and
he's I forget what he said his exact
quote to her which is so great is like
he says yeah he goes you know what I
need
you know what I need like his one thing
was like [ __ ] the one thing I wanted
was to just go in and
off myself in a clean Medical
situation and you and your [ __ ]
Facebook friends [ __ ] that up for me
so now I have to be alive
so it's sad I don't know I don't know if
I'm for letting young kids
kill themselves
but I guess we're gonna let them make
all the decisions they're gonna like be
able to change
biological Parts they're going to be
able to take themselves out
just let you know
it's not a great
it's not a great way to run a society
by letting very young people who are
deemed mature like how is that somebody
just makes a case for their own death
and you go you know they were very
mature
they were respectful
and they detailed why they don't want to
be here anymore
and we found it persuasive
show and is is it a pod where you write
is it a pod is that how you kill
the pods are in Europe so I don't know
how they do that I think I read about
this I think it's like a lethal
injection where they stop your breathing
and collapse your
but it's crazy that young like that
young people would be allowed to do that
you know
Nicholas Cruz the shooter of Parkland
uh the Parkland
shooting Alex Jones by the way now owes
a billion dollars
965 million some crazy number
a wild number about Sandy Hook but this
is not that one this is Parkland it's a
different one they both happened okay
now Parkland school shooter was spared
the death penalty
he killed 17 people
and this is what I don't understand we
let a diabetic 23 year old
who has one eye and who's upset kill
himself
but Nicholas Cruz will spend the rest of
his life in
jail
this is insane everyone knows right Chen
Wang 14 year old shooting victim Peter
Wang's cousin yelled during a news
conference after the decision was read
we need Justice I agree Shen
Cruz 24 pleaded guilty a year ago to
murdering 14 students I'm not laughing
at this I'm just I'm laughing at the
idea of like a guy like screaming out
people don't scream out it's great
the three-month trial that included
graphic videos and photos from the
massacre in his aftermath
uh you know has led to the it's it's
[ __ ]
it's completely [ __ ] that I don't know
I mean the death penalty is tough but we
all know he did it
everybody knows he did it
you know people want closure
they want closure and they want the guy
they want the guy to die you can't get
angry at them for that
um
I wonder like what the jury deliberation
on that was
because you get I I wonder like against
it you might have had religious people
it doesn't seem like it doesn't seem
like too many of the Christians would be
against that but you might have had
people go well
he's Young
maybe they said he's mentally ill I'm
trying to think what the argument would
be
I guess you just some people are morally
against the death penalty there doesn't
seem to be any issue like he did do it
and everyone knows that I think he
admitted that didn't he admit that
does he want to die maybe he wants to
die like the kid in Canada we're not
letting him to spite we're doing it to
spite you
he seems like a guy that might want to
die like he's saying let me have it take
me out
most of them shoot a lot of these people
that do the shoot themselves
um he is not he stayed alive and he was
taken out
and kind of nicely actually they kind of
like swaddled him and brought him out in
a blanket put him in the car
rubbed them a little bit
you know
meanwhile they like shot a black guy
who's you know stopped to put something
in the mailbox but Nicholas Cruz was
kind of like treated pretty
well
um I wonder if any of the Parkland kids
came out like to David Hogg or did any
of them come out and comment on this
did any of them
I used to follow one of them on social
media but it was just it got very and it
got very like oh boy enough enough
what's David is he tweeting about
Ukraine if they get David David Hogg is
tweeting about the Ukraine I'm gonna
throw this microphone at the [ __ ]
TV if David Hogg is an expert at all in
Ukraine I'm going to go insane right now
we're looking at his Twitter feed and to
his credit I have not seen any Ukraine
I haven't seen any Ukraine
I I got to be honest I'm pretty
impressed
I'm pretty impressed
he's sticking to guns he's sticking to
his thing
he's taking some shots at Alex we got it
okay hey man
I gotta be honest David Hogg
know you crane good job
you're welcome on the show anytime
I uh you know
yeah okay
I'm pleasantly survived I thought and
I'm sure if we went deeper you'd find it
but I don't even want to I just wanna
let's just let's let it let's let it be
a beautiful moment where David hog is
just taking his time and going you know
because he's got he doesn't have to do
the Ukraine it's a lot going on Alex
just got hit with a billion dollars and
this gun stuff there's there's you don't
you know he's doing the climate he's on
that he's on that beat
he just doesn't have to do the Ukraine
I'm just I'm just angry about the
Ukraine because I
can't fathom I don't know where this
passion came from
it is nice to Don boss we see dunbas
again it is beautiful
um but you know yeah there it is I mean
it's Austin that's literally Austin Tech
day look the exact same give it back
give it back let Putin have it do not
do not go to a nuclear war over this do
not say he's losing and uh stop saying
that like
you know and then there's all these
articles like well what will we do if he
fires nukes well we fired it's like hey
hey
[ __ ] give him the give give him what
he wants I I hate to say this it's gonna
make me sound crazy right now and people
are gonna get very angry at me anger
than than maybe is is they've like you
know if they're not listening fully
listen to what I say here listen what I
say and and understand and and try to
understand what I'm saying here
if we go to nuclear war
we may be the reason
we may be the reason we go to nuclear
war
I'm telling you it's it's it's
strange
I'm not a Putin apologist I'm not a
Putin fan I don't think he's
swell
but I will tell you this if we end up in
a nuclear war at this point after kind
of seeing what I've seen it seems like
we may be the reason that we go in a
nuclear war which babies are people want
maybe some people want people like that
well
maybe people want it maybe people are
just so you because you know we've only
set up one outcome here and the only
outcome is like zelinski and Madonna and
Beyonce are just dancing on Putin's
grave like we've only put one Pathway to
a victory and that Victory is that
Ukraine gets everything they want Russia
is humiliated and the United States does
some like the Twitter party where we all
just [ __ ] smack Putin down
and like that's the only way that this
works out
you know in in the way that we have set
everything up that's the only way that
this works
so you know
I'm just saying
for everyone involved which is again
anyone that's alive
anyone that's currently breathing
G7 demands Russian withdrawal from
Ukraine pledges continued support in a
speech to the group of seven leaders
zelinski will load them here I say that
so well Voldemort of Vladimir zelinsky
called for more air defense after a
second day of Russian attacks on
civilians see this is again we're just
ratcheting this up
The Group of Seven Nations on Tuesday
committed themselves to continue
supplying Ukraine's urgent requirements
for military equipment and demanded that
Russia quote completely and
unconditionally withdraw all of its
yeah hey
[Music]
yeah just completely and unconditionally
withdraw all of its troops and military
equipment from Ukraine including Crimea
and the annex room right so there's that
there's that op there's option one where
Russia is humiliated on the world stage
in a in a massive public humiliation of
Vladimir Putin then is killed by the
elites of Russia who
um replace him with like I don't know
some type of like trans friendly body
positive leader
or we're gonna have a nuclear war it's
gonna be it's gonna be a nuclear
confrontation so it's one of the two
Russia takes the L they walk out they go
yeah sorry ah we tried we do suck we are
[ __ ]
we are stupid [ __ ] boy was that a
miscalculation like Putin gets out and
goes hey I I thought it would be easier
but
guess what we're [ __ ] and we [ __ ]
lost and the U.S is [ __ ] dope they
didn't fight but they sent the [ __ ]
on the they didn't fight they didn't do
that but they sent arms to the Ukraine
and they put zelinski on the covers of
all of their magazines and they wiped
all the Neo-Nazi Ukraine stuff from
social media because there was a lot of
that and they got all of that and then
they they said I was a crazy
[ __ ] because I am I'm a crazy
[ __ ] Putin goes I'm a crazy [ __ ]
and that's why I am leaving the Ukraine
I'm sorry join NATO join it in fact
we're joining NATO Putin goes Rush is
joining NATO we're disarming we're
turning all of our nukes over to Nato
we're joining or nuclear war
I don't know what's more likely
that or a nuclear Exchange
what seems to be more likely a a
Putin just having a [ __ ] aneurysm and
then turning around and going yeah we're
you know we were wrong we actually
welcomed NATO
we welcome the Ukraine and listen
remember when this started people got
mad at me because I had that comic on
and you're like you don't understand
it's more complicated and I'm like sure
it is but it's a war and here's a young
guy whose life's been turned upside down
he's a comic and we ended up being very
good looking we had him on the show and
people were mad at me they're like you
and I never said that like there wasn't
some blame with NATO or what I was just
saying the war itself sucks and any War
sucks because people are dying
but the more and more this has gone on
and the lack of Interest we have in
forcing any type of deal like we have no
age like nobody like none like like none
like Putin's like tried to make deals
we're like [ __ ] you bit like there's
been zero interest none more arms more
arms no deals another cover for
zielinski Vogue how about this I'll take
half a Crimea Vanity Fair cover solinsky
uh we'll do dunbas and we'll have the
Crimea [ __ ] you zelinski's at the Oscar
like there's been zero interest in
trying to save people's lives like no
interest from our country we just don't
care we're we like we print the money we
spend it on weapons people get rich I
get that but now it's time to cut the
[ __ ]
we've had our fun we've wedded our beak
with a war in Europe with whites and now
it's time to roll it back and give put
what he want and I'm telling you that I
know people are gonna they'll clip it
they'll be like you suck you're an
apologist just for the for the simple
fact
that I don't want the world
to end I would just let's start dealing
with these specifics
of what Putin wants which is like a
couple of shitty regions
and no NATO nobody's there's no more
NATO nobody's getting in NATO anymore
let's there's no more net nobody's
getting in NATO
that's it
and I'm not a Putin apologist I I I I
think he's mean
but like true like really
but I would say that it might be time to
just
you know
we've got problems here does anyone want
to die when this started did anyone
think we would die over this
did anyone did that cross anyone's mind
when this started that we might die over
this
did that go through anyone's head when
you heard this did you go oh this is
going to end in our in our fiery death
now so let's just start to work please
to ending this which no one wants to do
nobody seems to want to do it but it's
literally the only Humane and moral
thing to do by allowing both parties to
leave with a little dignity here and to
All or Nothing attitude
is probably just going to lead to a real
big problem unless Putin
has just an about face and does what he
what he wants you know or I'm sorry does
what we all want him to do which would
be nice I'm not against that but he's
not going to do it and if they kill him
they're gonna put in like Sergey shogu
or there's other [ __ ] over there that
I've read about they're not exactly uh
daisies they're gonna come in there and
they're also some of them want them to
just start firing away right now like
some of the hardliners when he did this
were like more
now
so I think we all just have to realize
that like you know this is not worth
dying over I feel bad for the citizens
of the Ukraine I feel bad for them
I feel bad for them
I understand that it sucks
I feel bad for some of the Nazi people
who you know because some of them are
Nazis there and it's not good but I even
feel bad for them because I'm mature and
I go that's gotta suck you're just a
young Ukrainian Nazi in America you
could be a young Nazi and like you get
over it you eventually get a girlfriend
it comes whatever but you're just a
Ukrainian Nazi and then all of a sudden
missiles and the house is done
America you can get over being a knock
you join uh whatever you know you you go
to rehab or you [ __ ] get into the
punk scene but the Nazi Punk scene and
then eventually like you you get into
the other Punk scene that goes we're not
really affiliated with that and you
still throw your life away but it's you
know it's more musical I don't know so I
feel bad for everyone involved here but
I'm just saying it's time it's time now
to cut it out
it's time to cut out like we've had
enough we've done enough and
um
we appreciate it so we'll see everybody
next week if we can interesting episode
on the patreon with Andrew Tate who is
the much maligned uh uh Romanian leader
of the manosphere that we had on who was
a lot of fun
him and his brother we went we had
Stakes
I mean they wanted they were going to
Dubai but they said if not we could hunt
bears in Transylvania
kind of alluring we want it you know
we'll go back we'll be back to Romania
but
you know again he said you know he's
he's really fun on the patreon and he's
you know I mean again people are not
gonna love
everything he says but he comes across
very reasonable and um so we have him on
and he speaks you know about this too
but if there isn't a nuclear war we'll
see you next week if there is we're
going to skank fast doing a lot of shows
there we're getting Nick Mullen Lewis
Gomez together for an old reunion
Ambassador radio which we will then
hopefully put out as an episode as well
love those guys we'll see them soon uh
thank you everybody and again encourage
your elected leaders call them tonight
and tell them to stop supporting the
Ukraine
call your electedly if you want to live
call your Congressman call your senators
and tell them it is time to stop stop it
now we've done enough it's fine we've
made our point just call your
Congressman call your senators and say
Hi how are you is this uh is this the
office of uh Joan whoever these people
are and go listen
we got to stop supporting Ukraine this
is Betty from Flint Michigan and I'm
telling you right now we got to stop
this [ __ ] because there's going to be a
nuclear [ __ ] War over the Ukraine
what the [ __ ] is going on
um but all right we will see everybody
soon good night